los majestuosos mares de hielo que
cubren las zonas más frías de nuestro
planeta están cada día más amenazados la
mitad de los 215.000 glaciares de la
tierra están a punto de desaparecer
concretamente a finales de siglo ya sea
en la cima de las dolomitas italianas el
parque nacional de Yellowstone en
Estados Unidos o el del kilimanjaro en
tanzania en los pirineos franceses A más
de 3000 metros sobre el nivel del mar el
glaciar del suéez se derrite a una
velocidad alarmante
este marcador se hizo en 2001 el glaciar
estaba solo a un metro y 50 centímetros
y hoy está unos 200 metros el glaciar
pierde unos 10 metros de altura al año
en los alpes del Mont Blanc el glaciar
más largo de Francia se ha transformado
hoy en un mar de guijarros hace un siglo
el paisaje era casi irreconocible un
nuevo estudio estima que en el caso de
que la temperatura global aumente hasta
1,5 grados por encima de los niveles
preindustriales el 49% de los glaciares
del mundo desaparecería para el año 2100
y en el peor de los casos con un aumento
de 4 grados la cifra sería del 83%.
la iglesia
los glaciares Son como embalses son una
fuente fiable de agua en verano durante
las sequías y las olas de calor cuando
más lo necesitamos
Los investigadores también estiman que
el nivel del mar subirá entre 9 y 15
centímetros lo que cambiaría la faz del
mapa mundial